es un momento histórico el que se vivió
aquí en el philippe con esta victoria de
Nueva York quien hoy ha conseguido su
tercer título de Roland garros pero
especialmente su título número 23 de
Gran slam convirtiéndose en el tenista
con más grandes en la historia de la
tenis fue un partido bastante Bueno
antes de especialmente una primer set
bastante apretado en el que el noruego
parecía ir liderando las cosas estaba
dando un tenis bastante bien construido
mostrándose bastante valiente también
intentando muchas cosas
batallando no solamente encontrando Cómo
leerle el fuego al noruego sino sobre
todo también parecía que físicamente no
estaba al cien por ciento Pero él
batalló hizo muchísimos esfuerzos para
poder llevarse esa primer manga en un
timbre siete seis Sin embargo a partir
del segundo set parecía que no hubiera
de alguna manera como restaurado todas
sus energías y comenzó a dominar el
partido y así lo hizo hasta el final
que parecía no lograba ya se veía muy
frustrado no lograba cometía muchísimos
errores finalmente
con muchísima gallardía se ha quedado
con ese segundo set seis tres y ya para
el tercer set a pesar de que caspio
trató de regresar y de meterse una vez
más en el partido a pesar de que veía
como llegaba esa ventaja por parte de
seguramente desestabilizó mucho a Ruth
desde el punto de vista de no solamente
físico sino sobre todo mental ahí fue
digamos donde lo dominó más que todo
pues trató de llegar un poco más
adelante y finalmente no logró quedarse
con ese tercer set que terminó en unas
siete cinco fueron tres horas y 13
minutos de partido para bueno marcar la
historia del tenis y un Novak Djokovic
estado prácticamente de rodillas en esta
cancha de la sin poderlo creer y bueno
fue allí abrazar a toda su familia a sus
entrenadores y se convierte entonces en
bueno el más grande tenista de la
historia El que sigue dominando la
historia del tenis Y a partir de este
lunes
que vuelve a ser el número uno mundial